who says games are a waste of time when
they can make you a millionaire I'm Dave
and welcome to your rags to riches GS
news update during the 2015 Game Awards
Bethesda announced a new promotion where
one lucky Elder Scrolls online player
will win 1 million dollars just for
playing the role playing game this is
part Bethesda's million reasons to play
campaign which began in October on
social media when the developer asked
fans to share their favorite parts the
game this new sweepstakes gives that
name a whole new meaning I guess the
meaning is each reason is now a dollar
it sounds Banksy fans share with us and
the community their favorite reasons for
playing we're excited to now share
something with one of them you can enter
the sweepstakes by visiting the Elder
Scrolls online website and completing
the entry form by January 10th then all
you have to do is log into the Elder
Scrolls online and play during the promo
period between the 7 3rd and January the
10th for sure increasing your bank
account romatic lee the winner will be
chosen at random on monday februari
first 2016 and on top of the 1 million
dollar grand prize that one person gets
Perez de will hand out three hundred
thousand crowns the Elder Scrolls online
in game currency to 1000 second-place
winners so will your chance at the Elder
Scrolls lottery be reason enough thank
you to jump into the game let us know in
the comments section below or you can
find me on Twitter our regular Dave I've
Roger Elder Scrolls news make sure it's
stay tuned to gamespot com